okay hello everyone we are continuing
our design review about calculus and
algebra for the upcoming version of
language
and
i think the first thing we had been
talking about previously was
maybe we can take that a little bit here
is function poles
um adam had not been here for that
discussion
um
and uh
the main thing i was concerned about
was the name
and the fact that what it's giving
is not
you know sometimes it's giving the
actual positions of poles and sometimes
it's giving a conditional expression
that represents
where the poles are
right right because the conditional
expression it
represents infinite sets of balls
right and so what else are we doing but
they're not that they are
okay so they are less implicit than an
implicit representation
i know
i know they have been unraveled much
like reduce would unravel a
representation of things but they aren't
but the problem is that you know length
of function poles of function is going
to give the wrong answer
yeah length can never return infinity i
think
we only have finite lists as far as i
know right right now that's correct
and probably
so actually what
yes
those things are infinite sequences
i know
but they're not influence so they're
like
okay so look the problem with this
sequences i i understand i understand
but i don't think this is really going
to work i'm sorry i think you know
either you've got to say
okay are there other cases in which so
reduce
turns
equations basically into equations
is that a fair
statement
yes otherwise it takes one relation into
another relation
another you know
predicate one predicate into another
predicate right
so this is a case
what are other cases where we are trying
to return
infinite sequences
like you know for transcendental root or
something that can represent a
transcendental root can represent an
infinite sequence of
values
and um
or not not true but not really but
it's exactly the same we do for solve
and solve values
if you do solve sine of x equals one
that you that's what you will get
no actually i want to be more extreme i
want to do sole values
obviously so that's that's that's very
very very much there do i notice i think
the pie has its head chopped
off that's a bug that needs to get
reported
so nobody else can do it scott could you
take a screenshot and report that
oh boy and what are you supposed to do
with this
well
short of having iffy sequence that's
that's the best way no that's not a good
answer i mean in other words what we've
what we don't have here is a bunch of
functions that deal with okay so
basically what we've got here is a
okay i think this is a separate
discussion and it actually
is not completely unrelated to this
multi-computation discussion that i'm
we're having
starting off tomorrow
um
the uh
hmm
okay i mean this is a structural issue
what we do with these kinds of objects
are there any other places where we're
producing these
reduce solve or the two biggies um
dissolve has the the parameters that it
generates
yes yes that can happen if there are
eigen values and there are infinitely
many of them
[Music]
okay so can we get a bucket of all of
the places where there's examples of all
the places where this is happening
because to me
there need to be some functions that
just deal with these infinite objects
they're making sense
so you can do things like find the first
five of them or something take a sample
of these take random variants of these
all kinds of things like this
am i making sense
you know testing where the two of them
are equivalent
another very useful thing to be able to
do
um
the uh
i mean basically
we're about to recreate what old georg
cantor did
because he was interested in what he was
interested in limits of trigonometric
series right that's what caused him to
invent set theory
so we're probably going to have to go
down something like the same path but
you know 140 years later maybe we can do
a better job
um and not end up with a bunch of
paradoxes and weird tight constructions
and so on
or at least know what we're getting into
anyway okay i i am not a big fan
of um
i mean do we think function poles is a
drat i mean the problem is that for
meromorphic functions
this is
well i guess it isn't even just
metamorphic it's some for functions with
a finite number of poles this is a
pretty straightforward thing
yes
well maybe we should just do it this way
for now because it's going to require a
more serious change can we look
maybe we should do it and make it
experimental
because it's going to be useful for the
cases for the well-defined cases what do
you guys think
yes yeah
okay all right were there any other
questions that came up yesterday and
this or whenever it was we did this in
this first section
no
okay all right let's move on okay so
we've gotten down to this right which we
come up with a new name we came up with
a new name for that which ends with list
instead of representation
well
what isn't it what is it polynomial sum
of squares list
okay fine
and then the other one we're going to
hold on
until we can redesign the proof object
yes okay so that needs to fork off a
meeting i mean that again
that's yet another thing that needs to
go into and scott if you can make sure
that's added to the agenda for
multi-computation tomorrow is proof
objects
sure
um
and and that needs another function that
applies it that that doesn't prove a
proof checker fun
we need a proof job well i understand
but we're going to have a general
version of that right that's what we're
going to do
we're not going to have you know
75 different ones
you're the one who's pushes for despite
the festival of special functions here
you know you're always the one who's
pushing for um
um general solutions yes and so that's
what i'm pushing for too i'm i'm with
you i'm not
right i'm not obstinating in any way
okay
um
so sander is commenting even if you have
infinite lists you need to order them in
the case of two infinite sets
exactly sander so it can't be done in
general
what can't be done
it can't be a lazy list
in general
um
i mean you see roger
let me make a philosophical comment okay
which i have become acutely aware of in
recent times okay so
these
you know i am very glad i understood
less
about
uh
essentially term rewriting 40 years ago
because
i would never have thought that what we
did in smp and now in orphan language
would have worked
that is
to
you know
take the first transformation rule that
applies and iterate until you get a
fixed point
because i now understand that there are
just a you know
an infinite number of paths it's all
rather complicated it's not obvious why
you take that path rather than another
but it turns out in practice it doesn't
matter
and so again
i'm suspicious about these claims about
it can't possibly work
we'll go down the path see if that's not
a problem right i mean my big
philosophical understanding recently is
while our evaluation scheme has worked
the logic programming evaluation scheme
did not work in practice
and it's interesting to reflect on what
worked and what didn't
and that's you know kind of a part of
the big story that we have to go over
this multi-computation thing is finding
another
evaluation scheme that in practice works
so to speak
and i think that's not unrelated to this
infinite lists question
i'm not i'm not exactly sure of all the
connections but but certainly related to
proof objects
okay anyway game theory solver so
so this is this is really fourth you
know future
so in in the general
more than two players game you need to
do it's effectively equivalent to
polynomial solving
okay
and so that's an application of this
polynomial stuff for the algebra stuff
and we've
and when are we getting the main game
theory thing that's going to be in
13.0 right 13.1
so we're not going to have any game
theory in 30 no no
okay
but it's going to be wonderful for 13.1
right okay
i didn't know that that was a um
uh
yeah sandra is commenting
taking an infinite set of solutions and
saying which ones occur within a finite
region yes that is an obvious thing to
want to do yes one of many right
there
i mean i don't know whether we have that
even
right now if you specify a region
in the xy plane for example and you have
a bivariate version of this some uh sort
of reduce output or something do we have
something that gives you that yes
you can add the constraints to the
system
or
oh it's the same thing in function polls
yes i understand that but i'm saying
afterwards cookie after
uh
yes you could still do that
how
not that easily you you would have to
turn them into into equation and and
they're not the correct right so the
question is
so yeah there there is no easy
pre-packaged way to do it no no
steven you're on to something that we've
talked about before and we've had
ongoing discussions on the side that we
need to do provide more functions that
can make something
make reasonable use of the output from
reduce one of the things we did before
early on was to find another reasonable
use of the output of reduce and that
became another function called find
instance right
okay but this thing of enumerating
within a region and making that easy
to do
is another one that's very reasonable
okay fine have a think about it i mean
let's that's what we can get to okay
let's keep going here
um
okay
what should we look at here do we have
examples for this
uh yeah actually that's a huge benchmark
3000 examples
no i understand but tell me what what's
the exciting thing here this is this is
okay so this is a
precision sort of a corner cases for
algebraic functions that it does better
and people got excited about it sam
blake you know
right worked on this uh we we brought
him in
to to right so what's an example
right so if you took anything from the
resource function there's an integrated
algebraic resource function yeah okay
just give me an example well i'm sorry
we didn't give an example here but
defender can maybe give one yeah okay uh
i could just uh
send one i mean he's just keep sending
me examples so
i just said in a minute
okay yeah yeah so let me see if i can
find
okay let's keep going here sure
bilateral so we have bilateral z
laplace transform the bilateral laplace
transform correspond to
the fourier transform and likewise this
one the bilateral c transform correspond
to the
discrete time fourier transform
okay why is it important
because in signal processing the z
transform and laplace transform is
defined as the bilateral one with no
mention of the unilateral one
so we previously had the unilateral one
yes
so we've now added bilateral you know i
so hate this way of doing things and
examples i so hate it
of defining things i so hate that we
really should avoid it and we've got to
avoid this as well come on guys
and what's all this weird stuff so this
is a conditional expression and then why
is this being percent sub 1 why are we
cutting that off we should be able to
just evaluate the conditional expression
yeah why are we doing that yes we don't
need to agree yeah okay so just clean
this up
this whole general question of pedantry
what is our calculus of patentry
so what is uh
what is that is that something for
children or
what pedentry
oh being pedantic oh when when
oh
no not that kind of it probably is it
comes from the same route okay
or something
no this is no this is actually very
important here this is called the
uh the rock the region of convergence
okay
okay and that's
that's very important when you're going
to inverse transform these things
um
that that you have the correct region of
convergence you get a different answer
actually but so if we do the inverse
bilateral z transform it eats
conditional expressions it does yes
exactly
the same thing is true for melon
transforms by the way
and the same thing is true for
unilateral transforms people have been
asking for it and as we upgrade them
we're able to put these out
let me understand something else what
can eat conditional expressions can
integrate each conditional expressions
should be yeah
but the integrate is one of those
halfway houses that hasn't been
sort of updated for for a number of
years we have a very serious project to
do a complete overhaul of integrate
which is not ready now but it will be
soon okay in which case it will eat
anything
omnivorous omnivorous
that's a tremendous um
yeah i mean mathematica only needs one
function right sold do you need anything
else in life
solve my problems i think that's the
wrong
no that's the that's a that is the wrong
paradigm thinking no it's the right
problem no it's not it's it's a pure
mathematical paradigm way of thinking
about things as soon as you think
that you're going to you know represent
things with programs solve is not the
only thing you need
right
it's hard to have a function that says
program my problem
right
the um
okay
so that's just there are two examples he
sent me three thousand these are two of
them
so
okay
the basic idea that thing like you know
nested radicals or things which can be
transformed by linear substitutions or
bilinear substitutions or whatever are
now done quite nicely
it's it's kind of nice it does look nice
yeah i mean they're very elegant and
he's put a lot of work into getting the
quality right so he's got a benchmark
which tests quality not just
whether it can be done or not
these are basically efficient tricks
they're way more efficient than trying
to do the full
um rish
which is not even ever done hasn't ever
been done by the way nobody's been
done that the algebraic case and so
uh but these are
kind of a bunch of tricks that that peel
off
another set of slices of algebraic
functions that can be done efficiently
some of them using grobner basis some of
them using other tricks and so on
right
and it does resolve few issues that
we've had with these this class of
problems um the other thing is he's very
careful about uh checking that the
solution is valid everywhere no branch
cut issues
what do you mean if there is a branch
card well he might add a compensating
factor in front you know which takes
care of the branch you know x i mean
like you know ratio of things which will
eliminate it but he avoids doing that
because that kind of is ugly
so
it's going to throw a lot of polishing
right now just to make sure that we have
kind of minimal uh compact usable
answers so you know that would be
important for different integration
because that's the consumer of these
things
so if we have branch cuts which are you
know hidden inside it's hard to find
them
right
so i mean a lot of work is going to the
global
quality of solution not just local
correct it is interesting the artistic
character of integration is interesting
and uh yeah anyway okay
that's what this is integration art
okay all right so yes let's let's yes
yes all right okay complete integral you
have to punch up there
yeah
so the background this was a package in
version three point also in that sort i
put it into d solve for version 6.0
we had to give a message because it
doesn't quite fit in so now last time we
requested that we should have a function
that actually exposes this to users
directly
this is is
guys
no it's an animated image yeah i know i
realized but i mean i think yeah it's
just something i've used for talks and
people thought that really explained to
them what was happening yeah well fair
enough
yeah and this is the next step though
stephen you know from
oh i don't disagree i mean i don't
disagree at some point though
i mean as we work on these new sort of
how-to-ish pages that will be another
whole dimension of how we document
things um but
yeah i mean and perhaps these will get
broken out and get a bit more prominence
in that case
um
sander is is uh excited or something on
the live stream
the
um okay
people are asking for more animations
and and
okay well interesting well we've
so just so you know we've just completed
i think the infrastructure step
here for our documentation that in that
our build systems and so on can deal
with animated images
so
yeah
we've cleared a path well that's that is
using the animated image function right
yes
but but it needs to work in our build
systems you see no i realize right okay
but then there's a whole different story
of producing
yes
and producing ones that i mean i think
this is a nice simple one which i get
the ones where it's like
the thing that i like about this one
is that i you know i can kind of pick it
up anywhere in the cycle and understand
it the things that drive me crazy with
these videos where you know a set of
things happen and it's like well what
just happened what just happened you
know and i ended up swiping back and
forth on it and
and so on if you click the link you'll
actually see the whole example later on
you know if there's a link over there to
the example and that will show the full
details of how that got constructed from
the complete intent sorry what there's a
link to the paragraph above that's a
hyperlink hyperlink here there's there's
a yeah exactly the backlink too it
should work
there your application so it gives them
great detail how this was achieved
and it's not showing but i actually
don't forget when you have all of these
random options i can eyes yeah i've done
it it's not showing up just right now it
was done probably uh yes last night this
morning i don't know it's not sure
update yeah that's okay no problem it
shouldn't matter okay all right let's
let's understand this complete integral
function okay
gives a complete integral for the first
order partial differential equation with
independent variables what is a complete
integral it says that in the first line
that's a solution that depends on as
many arbitrary parameters as the number
of variables in the equation
so it's a bit like almost like an od
kind of solution it's got arbitrary
parameters rather than arbitrary
functions which is typical of pd's and
this is an alternate approach due to
moji and people like that in the i don't
know 19th century whenever
so what they thought was okay we need a
kind of basis for constructing for
solving the initial value problem the
cauchy problem for nonlinear pd's and
that's the way to do it you have these
very simple complete integra they call
complete because starting from those
you can construct envelope solutions
which then uh actually solve real
problems
so on their own they are not interesting
useful well they are but
the real fun is in actually taken
envelopes and envelopes envelopes and
singular solutions and that kind of
stuff and solving the complete cauchy
problem for non-entrepreneurs okay let
me start off with the first example here
okay so
we've got a pde here
and
you're giving a result yeah that
involves two that involves arbitrary
constants not functions here right
exactly
so
that was why i wasn't paying enough
attention here
depends on arbitrary constants as
opposed to depending like if i solve the
wave equation or something that in
general i would get something that
depends on arbitrary functions exactly
so when can if i gave it the wave
equation if i gave complete integral the
wave equation what would happen this
particular to first order pds because uh
second order p don't quite have this
kind of simple script but if you took
the travelling way
you know the way for you could do uh
partial with x plus partial y equal to
zero for example
then that's the
traveling wave equation you know the
the first order pd not the second order
pd just a linear let's take a linear pd
nothing more than that
and you see what happened now
so what you get back is
essentially something that's going to
let you
construct the general solution general
now if you did desolve the same thing
you'll actually see that you get back
an arbitrary function
so the same input these all do something
different
right so
i see so if i gave okay so you're saying
if i give this to d solve exactly yeah
you get a different output hopefully
there you are
now what you get is um you know like uh
[ __ ] or advanced null coordinates
so you're in those coordinates your pd
looks simple
so what this complete integra is a kind
of much raw much raw form of what you
call it of the solution but for for real
non-pds it's the only way to proceed to
solve initial value problems
so
it only works for first order pdes right
because they reduced to first order uh
to first order systems of od so really
you're solving ods there's no nothing
new for for first order pds you're still
in the you know because of sharpit and
jacobi and people i'm confused by
something just in terms of the
cardinality of solutions yeah i don't
understand how these can both be
solutions here
well the point is the first one is
called complete but it's not complete
sense that it covers a whole manifold of
solutions it's just called complete
historically and i think we should do
that
so so you're saying
i mean the cardinality is much lower for
this set of solutions than this one
right
um well i think it's different how it
counts because you've got two arbitrary
constants over there versus one function
i mean one of them is a function it's
the the right it's a yeah the function
that's a function from reals to reals
and that's two reals in the previous one
so we can't say it over there uh in the
output but starting from that
complete integral you can then generate
an arbitrary function
which is the general solution so
the idea is how how i showed it in my
example over there that's exactly so
what you do is you take make c2 as a
function of c1
so now you're an arbitrary function in
the solution
and then you take envelopes this is a
well established theory for these first
order pds
that it's all over textbooks so so you
have n parameters you make one of them
depend on the remaining n minus one
in an arbitrary way with an arbitrary
function and then you can solve the
initial value problem wait a minute wait
a minute wait a minute c2
is something which
you're saying
we can think of c2 as being a function
of c1 here
yes
and if we do that we can transform
that thing which just had a bunch of
variables into something which is like
the arbitrary function yeah in fact you
can do it for both the traveling of the
equation and for any equation except
it's bit it's a bit cumbersome because
it's some algebraic solving okay so i i
i need to ask a slightly fancier math
question
so
first
remind me okay so
okay
when people were trying to solve the
three-body problem for example
okay
the
okay
first of all the idea of constants of
the motion
yes is is an idea we don't yet have that
is given a pde or given an ode even that
that's an ode case i'm sorry i'm just
trying to understand this so first
question is given an ode
we could in principle have a function
which derives the constants of the
motion for the ode is that a true
statement
there used to be something of this sort
in a package i don't know how good it
was but yes i've seen that i mean so you
have constant of motion
okay we have nothing for that
okay
but now here what do you mean by
constants of motion
sorry well in like the two body problem
right the you know the inverse square
two body problem how do you mean
do you mean like a hype a surface in
which to yes okay that's what you mean
by constant emotion yes i mean that the
solutions are parameterized in the
two-body problem for example
the solutions are completely
parameterized by a few parameters you
know in the in and like that's what you
mean that's just a general solution
well yes but the point is that that
that the
let me try to think how this works the
reason that i'm bringing this up is
because i think this is related to your
what you're describing i'm just trying
to understand what your this thing that
you're describing with first order pdes
that there is a representation just in
terms of
i'm still trying to wrap my head around
the difference between a representation
in terms of constants and a
representation in terms of arbitrary
constants versus arbitrary functions
because i sort of assumed
oh i'm confused here
so d solve when it's solving pdes only
gives arbitrary functions is that true
it doesn't ever give arbitrary constants
no that's the point that starting
version six we decide to obsolete the
complete integral package which was in
standard packages and it's given from
dsor with a message so if you look at
one of the non-linear examples in my
you know uh examples over there then you
try desolder this almost same solution
with the message
so
i see i remembered that designed as yeah
and i remember you said that let's have
a message so we don't confuse people and
we need for ourselves as well to remind
us that you can't use the solution like
a typical pd solution
well that's the linear pd
that's the linear equation if you really
want a non yeah you want something
that's genuinely non-linear
i mean you could take the iconal
equation but there must be others over
there as well you can pick any one you
like it must have a spell okay so then
then what we had been doing
is this a non-linear one
i'm not seeing here
does that count as non-linear yes yes
okay fine yeah you can take that one yes
yes so
so you should get the same solution
hopefully from d solvent and complete
integral in fact we've now got one
framework for them both
but you don't in fact that's a function
that's an arbitrary function again no
it's probably using another method now
then squeezel it's still quizzilinus we
can still do those and try something
like d solve of uh partial u square with
x plus partial u it's related to y
square equal to 1 the iconal equation
if that doesn't work i'll give you
another one so
the u of x comma y yeah so you want
partial x square plus partial y square
equal to 1.
but not double x not double derivative
no just just one derivative just single
derivative
open that okay
there you are
now that's the same solution should get
from complete integral but without a
message
and that is what you made the point last
time that we need to
have exposes functionality separately
okay but under what circumstances okay
so a complete integral
is
a solution with essentially numerical
parameters as opposed to function
parameters yes
and the question is the question is
it is a solution but how many more
solutions are there right and that's
where you need the envelope construction
that you need to take one parameter
families
look at the envelopes and then you get
these more general solutions so it kind
of it's a little like a basis for the pd
it's not the full solution space for
sure
but that's true
in general
okay
like when you find an integral
you are just finding a thing who's you
know whose derivative
is equivalent to the you know to the
original and there may be many such
integrals right yes
and
actually
you know if you do that if you do double
integral you will get unknown you will
get not just constants you will get
functions
if you do that for us you know for
integrate and say
i forgot what it called constant the
options constant
it will generate unknown functions for
you
arbitrary okay
and is that it's generating arbitrary
functions for the same reason that a
a
second order pde is generating arbitrary
functions sure like the
you know the
dilemma solution for the wave equation
is
like a forward moving wave and backward
being like f of x plus no no i i know
but but but you're but it's the same
reason it is the same reasons yes yes
exactly that you i mean that's what you
need to solve the problem yes sure sorry
no but the the thing i'm trying to
understand is that for a first order
equation so
a second order
you know the reason that the reason that
they're arbitrary functions is that you
have two or more independent variables
yes but i mean you're saying any double
integral if i were to represent it with
all its constants would have a
a
an arbitrary function in it obviously
right
i mean if there's variables at least
yeah right
okay
well i mean this is clearly a a function
that helps clarify an unbelievably
complicated situation yeah and i've
given examples to explain the hamilton
yokoba equation i've tried try to give
as many examples as possible to clarify
what's happening over here in the
applications
so
and it's it i mean
when we have something like hamilton
jacobi equation there's a question that
i have which is we don't have an entity
store of those things do we i mean we
should have just like we have a thing
with plain curves and so on we should
have all of these named equations
somewhere
raj and i've talked about that i don't
know from what yeah
actually um i i don't think we've come
up with a super good solution yet
stephen
uh about what to do with it because
well why not do the same thing that
we've done at least do the same thing
we've done for plane curves yeah i mean
if nothing else we could do just not
have them have parameters and things
um well we've done that we've we've
already solved this problem for playing
curves we have them as functions which
have formal parameters
it may not be the most elegant solution
but it's quite usable well we could we
should look at that why don't you look
at it yeah i mean yeah
i think that yeah i think so i think
that there's there's only so many
there's you know almost a few hundred
right i mean it's things like i don't
know what whatever the um
uh you know there's a plane curve right
now i can say something like if i take
that plane curve and i can say what on
earth is happening to my computer here
wow my characters are echoing
slowly that's really weird
um
i don't know why this is so slow as well
but
but this is you know what i would
imagine is that hamilton jacobi equation
is you know here it is right
so it's a bunch of you see this
stuff and here the algebraic equation
has
a i mean this may not be the best way to
do how do you know
how do you know
how many parameters you have well i'm
sure that's one of the properties here
see what i'm saying and what they mean
and stuff
well i'm sure that's one of the
properties here
in the 70 in the 80 rows of stuff i'm
sure that's one of the properties
yeah i mean so this is the kind of thing
i think we need for these named
equations yeah
and we've definitely talked about i'll
bring it up against roger when you meet
sure okay i mean so michael is the big
expert on these i think yeah i think
they were constructed i think eric
weissling i think was the person who
actually constructed them it looks like
an eric production
yes
um
anyway i i think this is what we need
for these named equations
yeah um
okay anyway that's complete integral
that seems
seems fine all right let's go on here
uh
wherever you had it
okay support for vector variables how
does that work right so there's a note
in the default also an example and this
came through the office by the yesterday
asking me whether i'd done this for 13.0
or not so i said yes i better be
reviewed today
so uh what you've done is to use the
fact that we know this vector was what
did you just say
i had an i've made a
note i had a note from
somebody say here asking what's happened
with what's
you know if we don't hear stuff it's all
getting tracked and you're going to get
asked questions yeah but i'm happy that
we just saw it in time so just this was
on the list anyway yeah yeah well okay
fine yeah okay so another note over
there which says what we do so basically
we use vectors to specify that something
is a vector variable and matrices
respectively
ah there's a note over there and there's
also a link to an example i hate this
i hate this but i mean
i hate this i mean so that that's
something in the bucket of stuff for the
equation it's like a constraint except
it's essentially a
a declaration that's part of the
equation right
yes
you know i'm sorry to say this is part
of the long-running what is a variable
question
yes
kind of kind of not the thing is that
i think that
this it can be in the equation but it
should also be able to be in the
argument structure
so we've done this we use vector
variables
and tensor variables a lot in
optimization
and
you know yes have it in the constraints
but also have it in the argument
declaration
um by the way and i don't know whether
this is maybe it's your fancy new uh
visualization but this
this process is using 100 of my cpu
right now
oh sorry
which which was the thing where it had
the fancy animation
complete integral maybe you want to
close that yeah i think it it might just
be running the animation forever but
it's also running an animation and
manipulating inside
but it's not supposed to be taking the
cpu to do that
no and i think i had a default duration
set as well over there but i don't know
what happened no but that's not the
point i mean
look the animated image should not be
using cpu yeah that's what was doing it
my cpu
usage is dropping
right the animated image should not be
burning cpu time that's not what it
doesn't it need it it doesn't do that
right so something went wrong so you
need to report that and chase it down
rather than having it be the case that
everybody who has these lovely
uh
you know desirable
animated documentation examples have
their computers eaten alive
um
okay
well i mean i understand what you're
doing here it's good functionality i
don't particularly like the way it's
done but i don't have a better
suggestion and i know this is what
we are
i mean
you know unfortunately what this is like
as a type declaration and what we tend
to do instead is to have rappers for
things
this is a rapper
it's not a rapper the rapper would be
the element
no
i understand but that's not right the
correct way to do it would be to say
that you
is instead of just being a naked
variable you it's some kind of vector
view or something or vector of u type
thing
that would be the way that we would
normally do it that's that's another
wrapper
no it's a wrapper around the data as
opposed to an indirect wrapper
in some kind of type world
right the thing is this is this is like
declaring a value for the variable
right this is a declaration about the
variable as opposed to something that is
right there in the symbolic structure
because the truth is that this thing as
you grind through it and as you solve
with it
it you know it is going to be completely
equivalent to having a thing if we had a
thing called uvac or something you know
if we had a thing that was the the
vector u you know if you write it as u
with a little arrowy thing on top
right and let's say there was a symbolic
representation of that that was elegant
and the the you know the way that we
would actually prefer to do it is to
write in the equation u vector you know
with the with the arrow on top
of you know x comma
t or whatever equals whatever it is you
get what i'm saying that would be an
alternative thing absolutely rather than
this absolutely direct declaration yeah
yes
and actually now that you say that
maybe we could get the stupidest ability
to not rear its ugly head when we have
that
yes
yes that's been a that's been a big
challenge for us you know because
symbolic variables
you know are treated as scalars right
now there's a default type in the system
scalars right well maybe we could yes
maybe we could um not do a stability in
the case where we would be fantastic
stephen that actually would solve a very
long standing problem for us okay well
let's look at this then i mean so that
would be a wrapper that represents a
non-scalar object yeah
yeah and if we could get the stability
to back off yeah well i'm sure we could
yeah right that would be
okay that would be magic that would
all right fine let us analyze it i mean
that that's so that should be probably
in
um
i think by the way this is not
completely unrelated to the inserted
concept
for
i mean that this question about deep
stability right currently listability is
always top level stability yes right i
know what you mean
that's gotten me confused it's not even
documented what we do
you know you have to do an experiment to
figure it out
right but but i mean this notion of
i i think this notion of of dealer
stability as well as deep listability
yeah i got it i got it it's a good idea
okay fine let's can we can we um i guess
that would be for scott maybe we should
have a discussion maybe we can just call
it listability and that should be a
standalone meeting
okay and it's a part of the series that
i don't know what it was named but
that's the one we were talking about
inserted
um
so for now we keep this uh it's okay we
should keep this and this is also
consistent with other uses it's okay
yeah this is kind of if we get another
mechanism we will support that too right
okay all right okay fine
what is this
asymptotically solved value
well we've had these uh so
this means
this whole sequence of arsenal diesel
things that coming up here is for
systems
of uh
systems of of ordinary differential
equations
um
and so but but this basically says
everything has gotten a lot better
is basically what it says
and so
specifically what happens is if you have
linear systems with right with rational
function coefficients we can solve the
whole set of those differential equation
systems and difference equation systems
and for non-linear systems we can
decouple or triangularize them even if
they're big structural kinds of things
i see
so i mean in general
okay so the for linear differential
equation
what is the analog naive question i mean
the analog of like hypergeometric
functions for the discrete case is what
difference root
i'm sorry um i'm sorry the the
okay if you i'm sorry the most general
function that the general function that
we need to solve those is difference
root
okay polynomic functions
uh the analog of hypergeometric i don't
know that there is one
we use something called hypergeometric
term but that's basically like the terms
in a hypergeometric sum
so the analog of hypogeometric function
is basically the type geometric series
in some sense right the terms they call
hybrid geometric terms
but it's not quite the right analog
because
those satisfy first order difference
equations and the corresponding
similar differential equations
is basically a first order differential
equation with the rational function
coefficients and those functions are
called hyperexponential functions
and they're a little bit
uh simpler than hypergeometric functions
okay but we don't have them explicitly
we don't need them because you can sort
of write them out this um okay
all right what is this thing with
discrete limit and we're about to run
out of time here yeah this is just an
improvement to this function
where
where do you have an example showing
yeah i just just just
sort of chat itself so that'll be easier
um
yeah sorry and i'm just going to set it
right in
10 seconds sorry
yeah
so but these system improvements to both
dsolve and rsolv and asymptotic versions
that's really it's really good stuff
this is what you need when you model
things
okay i sent it off so this came through
tech support basically uh it's something
where people wanted us to do what some
programs do automatically namely
essentially convert it to an integral
and evaluate it
so
there you go
so so it doesn't try to eval i mean it
it will try to
convert it
it recognizes it as a riemann sum
basically exactly
so it's just it's just a case that we
weren't able to do previously right and
uh it was kind of important because we
have we're getting you know kind of
complaints for for whatever you know
please
so basically basically somebody had set
this as an exercise in some textbooks
yes and we can't do it okay
yes now we can yes and then lots of them
it's not just i mean there are lots of
them there's a whole class of them it's
not this specific so we just missed some
things in discrete limit great so we
fixed it yes exactly exactly perfect
yeah and somebody else had gone through
textbooks better than we had
well we had but we never looked at from
discrete limit point of view from this
you know so
ethan on our live stream is asking about
complex contour integration we do have
stuff going coming right so that should
have been listed as another integrate
improvement um so there are two things
but one thing is that when you actually
give a contour and we recognize it we do
use um
um
we do use sort of a residue-based you
know if it's if it's a metamorphic we do
use residue-based
computation and how do you specify that
i mean like like no no no no
let me finish yeah so
that that led to improvement in a
previous release in this release the
vendor has done some other things that i
think you reported some friend reported
uh
right and um
i can't remember exactly what it was now
but it was
with parameters in it and the other one
didn't have parameters in it so this
that's gone in and it's resolved a lot
of problems now
back to your other question
how to specify so you can specify a
contour integration with or integrate
but you have to specify the actual
contour
as a parametric curve
yeah
and but most people don't necessarily
want
you know they want to say the promise
contour or something yeah they want to
say sort of include this point exclude
this point include this strip i'm sorry
this
this ray exclude this fight so they want
a more
um a different and i think
the analog of constructive solid
geometry for for you know describing a
curve in the in the complex plane or
something right but you don't really
want to describe it that precisely
because it doesn't matter it doesn't
matter right right so we will come to
that
our plan is to do that post our big
update to integrate
right okay
so i mean this question about sort of
homotomically equivalent things and how
we deal with them is an interesting one
it is
i mean that's sort of that sort of
exactly and then the thing is that that
that kind of sort of first of all let me
just remark quickly that
we're getting into doing so so this
thing of specifying a contour in this
fashion is only really relevant for kind
of meromorphic functions or when you
want to avoid things that are not
metamorphic
and that relates to a particular theory
of integration due to cauchy where you
use residues right okay if you're
dealing with more general complex
functions which we are and we can
perfectly well deal with them
uh that's not so relevant anymore then
you actually need to give the real
contour where the value is just you know
it can't just but strong value right
it's the wrong value
but back to your question yes like
irrespective of that are things
equivalent or or not in some sense
i wonder what the general case of that
is going to be
because again i mean i hate to bring it
back to this multi-computation business
again it's that's a path equivalent
story that's a discrete path equivalent
story
in the case of these you know concerts
in the complex plane that's a continuous
path equivalent story
right i mean what's what's the question
you want to answer i mean what's this i
want to i want to know what is the
framework that we're going to use
because i'm thinking about like various
different proof paths
right you have a you know you have
multiple proofs
and there are different proof paths but
they are equivalent
and
but that's not how
i mean here as i said i think that the
the essential problem you want to solve
when you do contour integration is
include this critical point exclude this
critical point
include this strip not that strip i know
but but the whole point is that there's
a whole family of curves that are
equivalent in that sense
so the question is if you were to
describe if you were to write
parametrically some curve and you write
parametrically some other curve and you
say these are two curves are they
equivalent
for purposes of contour integration
yeah we can actually check that because
we know what the singularities are i
know and they're exactly the same then
yeah right i know the functions satisfy
certain conditions but imagine a version
of simplify or something that i mean
what i'm just trying to understand is
this is homotopically equivalent things
and that's a whole class of such things
whether they're proofs
whether it's
the point you don't need to check that
so what what you know given that you're
going to integrate a function
no i know it doesn't matter in the case
there's a whole point it doesn't matter
but the whole point is it doesn't matter
but i'm saying so i don't need to check
that they're homotopically equivalent so
that's like like
so the whole point of making efficient
algorithm is to avoid doing work i can
avoid doing that work yes i understand
that there's a separate question of are
they homotopically equivalent yes okay
so question is can one answer that or
what are the algorithms for answering
that right and and then
you know and but that that backs us into
various kinds of topology
and asking
um
you know homotopic groups and all this
kind of thing and i'm just trying to
understand what is our way of
representing
a a curve up to homotopy right we don't
have that notion we don't
and um
i i think we're going to need that
notion
like in a graph for example
we
yeah i mean i i think we're going to
need that notion
and anyway that's just part of the um
okay let's see more to more to look at
here
um
you can skip the rest well that's
exciting though how
oh yeah that's all in progress
spring has sprung what's happened to it
yeah
yes uh it's ready
right now but we need a month or two
more to actually uh
ship it but
it's quite a bit slow because you can't
record on i'm not saying that's an
excuse but i mean uh but
i'm reviewing this right now so it
should get done soon maybe you can
announce the tech conference or
something of that sort
we had a new person that that helped
contribute to this to record them and
prep the recordings
um it took much longer than we had
planned it for
that's what's where we're at right now
and one excuse or one thing that
uh devendra said was the technical setup
getting the right microphone
uh
all of that's all done in our video
recording studio here on site at the
company but when people do it at home
you have to kind of start all over again
with each one yeah
but i've by the way now got a decent
sort of mobile setup for doing that
stuff oh i am sure you do but you
probably
haven't but i haven't i was i was have
you iterated a few times
no it actually got nailed the first time
i mean this i but i hadn't been
traveling for two years so
i just you know went on a short trip and
brought some stuff and it worked just
fine okay um
okay let's see marco on a live stream is
talking about implicit listening plus
list instance yes yes yeah this whole
whole big discussion yeah all right well
good stuff okay i think we're done with
this um very good i'm a little bit
afraid of this exact number thing but i
guess we'll come to that in the next
version yeah
yep okay all right thanks a lot see you
all thanks to folks in the livestream
oh we're doing another one of these that
i'm being reminded
we have another one in what half an hour
oh it's about chemistry you guys
different set of people all right thank
you guys